dude don't you think don't you think
it's more mature to say
um I'm gonna figure out how to get along
with a man before before just breaking
up which is that was the question was
your child's life ever in danger no okay
I think as far as the way I'm saying
this okay let me know you sounded I'm
not saying it's just you I'm saying that
both of you should have worked on it
okay let me let me clarify that like
what you're saying about I I won't say
that my sons my son's dad was abusive I
never ever said anything bad about my
son's death I remember and you see lots
of people oh you're just like your
father I remember being in the
supermarket with my son and he was
missing about and I said to him do you
know what you're just like your mother
you're just like your mother I don't
know why I brought you out and this
woman stopped and said oh um if his
mother was here you know you shouldn't
be talking to him like that and he
looked at me and I looked and I started
laughing because I have never ever said
to him you're just like your father and
sometimes people sit there and they
don't realize that
this sign language this body language
this feelings children will pick up
these things some people need to be a
part but by what you're saying and how
religious you are and the fact that you
are married and the fact that you both
know that you need to grow and the fact
that you know the child's life wasn't in
danger the way I'm saying is that what
have separate rooms have separate rooms
in the same house and work out your
differences because at least the child
if you are adult enough to come this far
and when you talk about the trauma from
the previous relationship that's why
Oscar has shared treatment for a trauma
rather than pass it on so you're gonna
get back together with your husband
you're not going to have this Trauma
from previous relationship and you're
quite vocal and one thing that you said
that I haven't seen you say gonna do is
like come off social media don't be
influenced by it no it sounds like
social media had a big part of it and
the way you thought marriages should be
so now you know marriages are not like
that then no so okay let me just clarify
I think there's a lot of spec
calculations or something so yeah so
when I initially uh
okay so before I got pregnant let's say
oh no actually yeah before I got
pregnant is when we first had
conversations about him feeling like he
settled down a bit too young right now
that gave me red flags in the sense that
I felt like that to me meant he wants to
be out on the streets does that make
sense so when I say I didn't I didn't I
took that trauma in that was the first
initial uh year of meeting him let's say
and all of that it that sort of came in
it's only when I got pregnant
and then
um I said to him like even then I found
it quite hard to swallow assuming that
he might want other women because at
that point even though I came from
polygenous household I couldn't accept
my man being with other women and that's
when I say social media impacted me
where it said it to me especially them
times it was like oh men can't cheat if
men cheat their trash leave them all of
that blah blah right so obviously when I
after my daughter was born
couple of years later it we Revisited it
but it wasn't in the sense that oh I'm
going to be with other women it was more
him expressing that what if he can't
stay faithful to one person for the rest
of his life now to me again I was still
young I was only like 24 25 at that time
for me again it was like what do you
mean that means you're going to cheat
so it's almost like okay fine if you're
gonna cheat then I don't want to be with
you so we separated because for me I
couldn't swallow the fact that he might
in the future want to be so cool so you
left I thought you said no so well the
relationship up to the point where we
were arguing or I was being toxic or
unhappy so he was like I can't do this
right so obviously we separated after we
separated cool we've done our we've gone
our separate way again when I say
finding myself I'm not talking about
exploring other people or bodies I'm
talking about revisiting what who I am
and my course well and I understand that
but like when you you were talking
talking about earlier because a lot of
the things we're saying we're just
saying what you said back to you so like
earlier you said you did the dating apps
you you were going on dates you went to
Carnival and like that that sounds like
and I think that's where again a lot of
my like the society will impact you
because again people in my ear oh you're
young you're this girl why not date I
had to then ask myself I've got a child
I could date another guy is he going to
treat my child the same as her dad is he
going to love me is he not going to
cheat on me and then I have to say
actually I can't guarantee that so
that's why I haven't dated or moved on
thank you
so like you so how old your child five
six nearly six so you're you're not
going to be with a dad you think okay
I'm gonna start dating another guy you
would at least wait you know a good year
before you know they're really in the
child's life I have two children
um and obviously I'm not not with the
dad and whatever
um and I've had like uh maybe I've dated
one guy since didn't meet my kids didn't
speak to my kids like he knew their
names that was it because I'm not going
to fetch a guy into their life just to
be temporary so I think when when you
speak like that you you do need to know
that they're gonna be there but even
that so for me I again I date with
intention but even that deal with
intention is still very different in my
culture because in my culture we get
married very quick to meeting people
like I'm not in that culture but I I do
I date to marry that's what I personally
would like to do
um you know I wouldn't have chosen to
have kids this young if I'd planned it
and obviously I don't regret them but I
would still try to be as traditional as
I could
um but I think it is it's harder in this
generation and you've just got to be a
lot more careful
I had my son at 17.
that made me grow up yes
it wasn't it wasn't that I was going to
say oh I was too young you know
[ __ ] happens you do with it just get on
with it right and not wanted I think to
myself yeah I'm a single parent I'm
gonna start dating didn't think about
that at all it was just concentrate on
my child I didn't even think consider
dating at all but that's what I'm saying
that's what I did yeah that's what I'm
doing yeah like I'm not considering
dating that I said I'm not even mingling
with people I'm not intending if if I
met someone and I thought organically
and I thought oh my God they blow my
mind that's one thing you're not looking
forward well it's just okay when you say
that and then earlier you said you were
on dating apps it kind of like it was
just the initial breakup obviously when
you're in your feelings and you're
broken up and my friends are like oh
you're single because I haven't ever
been to school yeah it was the first
time I'm single and women our age were
all dating at that time 25 26. they were
all trying to date not even with kids
there's a lot of single mums trying to
do it in in our with my modern women but
again that's again what I had to revisit
I had to say to myself am I going to
find a man who's not going to treat me
yeah but you see like how it sounds when
you say it like your story like keeps
contradicting itself like it like I
haven't even really asked you like like
you've been going on like talking about
it and like volunteering this
information and then like you keep
contradicting yourself and I think the
reason is is because I am a clash of
cultures so I am very you know obviously
I'm Bangladeshi British Muslim and I
think the modern side is what is me what
I'm fighting against does that make
sense so the more I'm realizing actually
I'm not this model woman is the more
comfortable I'm getting in who I am I
don't I don't think you can really go
back like I I don't think you can really
claim traditional if you're separated
from your like your husband it's no when
I say traditional I say as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible